[Music]
Einstein was a great hero of mine and
he's played an important role in my life
in many ways I tried to write to model
my scientific expositions and style on
the early Einstein first for several
years I owned and lived in Einsteins
house in Princeton I was kind of his in
that sense a successor at the Institute
for Advanced Study
he added profound themes to our
understanding of nature at a technical
level
he really advanced although he didn't
articulate it explicitly by example he
advanced the idea that symmetry is
what's very basic to the operation of
fundamental law in the special theory of
relativity he showed that by postulating
symmetry that is that the laws don't
change although they might have if you
move past a physical situation at a
constant velocity the same laws still
apply to that different looking
situation that kind of very conceptual
idea of how physical law is constrained
set a new style in physics that that you
assume that the world doesn't change
when it might of under various
transformations that's been really
that's that really has been a dominant
theme of 20th century physics and of my
own work he carried it further in that
in the suspect in the general theory of
relativity where he postulated a new
kind of symmetry called so-called local
symmetry which is vaster and leads to
even more constraints on the possible
description of the world and even more
particular guidance about what the
equations should look like
and that kind of strategy has been a
spectacular ly successful in a
generalized sense although we need some
extra tricks but in the generalized
sense that's the main trick that allowed
us to figure out not only the correct
theory of gravity or actually a very
very good theory of gravity which is
Einstein's general theory of relativity
but also in the sub-nuclear domain where
we had to guess fundamentally new laws
for fundamentally new interactions which
were very unfamiliar the so-called
strong and weak interactions it turned
out that this hot kind of hypothesis of
grand symmetry was the right way to go
so in addition to being a beautiful idea
it's actually it's turned out to be an
extremely fruitful idea it's led us to a
description of interactions where or new
kinds of forces where otherwise we would
have been completely at sea
[Music]